así es durante la madrugada llegaron
grúas de alto tonelaje precisamente para
poder sacar a los últimos cuerpos que
estaban atrapados luego de que se
desplomó este vagón del metro como bien
lo comentas fueron al menos tres
personas las que fueron de último
momento rescatadas sin vida por lo que
ya están contabilizadas en los 23
muertos ya no hay más personas atrapadas
de acuerdo con las autoridades de
protección civil siguen los trabajos
para bajar estos vagones a la tierra y
poderlos retirar del lugar la jefa de
gobierno ha dicho que pues se iniciará
una investigación profunda y una
revisión estructural de toda la línea
que por cierto está cerrada en su
totalidad son 20 estaciones que
permanecen cerradas y se han dispuesto
490 autobuses para dar atención a los
pasajeros en esa zona de la ciudad al
oriente de la ciudad fueron 5 metros de
caída este paso elevado solamente tenía
una década de construido mario'
o algo las autoridades de la causa del
accidente
han dicho que van a realizar peritajes y
de ser necesario se haría una negación
externa lo cierto es que ésta
con múltiples fallas desde su
inauguración en 2012 hubo incluso la
necesidad de cerrar 11 estaciones de
esta línea en marzo de 2014 porque
presentaban fallas de compatibilidad
entre los rieles y las ruedas asimismo
tras el sismo de 2017 hubo daños en las
columnas que soportan este paso elevado
por lo que también permanecieron
cerradas algunas estaciones para darle
mantenimiento y rehabilitar estas
columnas
sin embargo presentaban las fallas
continuas en 2020 los usuarios de redes
sociales habitantes de la zona habían
mostrado como estaba desnivelado
precisamente un tramo en este en este en
este periodo de la línea 12 del metro y
después simplemente no se atendió por lo
visto porque se desplomó por completo
esta a través que se llaman ballenas y
los resultados ahí están se harán los
trabajos de reparación pero sobre todo
las investigaciones